thank you very much for being my guinea
pigs for uh for today it's always fun to
be the first uh first of a pi data
london session
so as mentioned my name is
anders i am norwegian i live in
copenhagen and have lived lots of
different places
i have a background in japanese business
actually
so i've had a lot of hats
i've
currently i am as mentioned the head of
the python enablement team at modis
management so my job is to make sure
that we have all the python tools we
need build up python infrastructure do
courses trainings workshops sort of be
internal consultants for all the teams
at uds management so you can imagine a
lot of quants a lot of trading i'm sure
you all you londoners know all about
that
um
so i'm this is the get repo that we will
be working with today
so i'll give you everyone a second to
clone it if you want to follow along of
course
that is
of course optional
i'm a bit curious before we start so i
assume everyone here is working with sql
or else i assume you wouldn't be here
but what kind of database are we working
with can i see a hand for postgres
okay
i'm a sequel
oracle
poor souls
uh
did i forget anything
what's in the other category here
all right excellent so we got like the
three main ones uh we got covered here
so the great thing is that sql alchemy
works with all of these
and it lets you sort of write
independently of your database to some
extent
so
if we jump over to the intro over here
so sql to me is actually a very very old
project in python
terms i tried to do some digging but the
history of it has sort of been moved
from garrett to to github and back and
forth but it's been around for a very
long time
it's
started as a way of layering on top of
these other python database tools that
we had
but
before we get into that
the reason that we use sql academy is
compared to many other tools that other
languages use or also just in python sql
alchemy doesn't try to hide away the sql
so it is a sql toolkit it's not a sql
abstraction
language it's not a dsl
it does support the object relational
mapper which lets you do some nice
things in hiding ways of the complexity
but again it doesn't try to hide away
the sequel and you can always dive down
into the sql parts
because one of the big complaints about
orms is that they are a leaky
abstraction that they
they mismatch sort of what you're trying
to do in your code and what's actually
happening in the database and that leads
to a lot of problems down the line
so
to sort of support this this
setup
sql alchemy has two main parts i briefly
mentioned them but we have the core and
we have the orm and we're going to dive
into what those two things are
but first
a bit of history
so pep 249 was introduced in 2001
it was actually two peps at the same
time
one was older than the other but they're
both registered at the same date
and that basically specified how do we
talk to database libraries from python
it's standardized standardized python
api to do that and that let all the data
providers write a database connector
that could be used
to do the same thing
so if we're taking an example that i
actually built into python so sqlite
as you are probably using everyday
because it's actually the biggest most
popular database in the world it's a
single file
embedded
database
so you can
you know import sqlite in python it's
right there which is great for a lot of
use cases
so we pass it a file name
and then we can use the db api
so usually the pattern looks like this
you have
a with
something.connect
to the connection string
this makes sure that at the end of this
block we close the connection and clean
up the
any lingering connections to the
database
and then we can execute some string
which is then sent to the database parse
the sql and then you get the result back
yes
of course
one more
so if you run this
nothing really happened right it feels
like it but if i look in my file system
over here and hit the refresh button i
now have this local.db again this is a
sqlite specific thing because it's a
file database it creates that database
so i executed this create table and now
i can reconnect to it and then i can you
know do an insert and then i can do
select
and if i look at this result i got this
list of tuples back
one in text which is the one i inserted
so you see already here a few things
that the ddb api is doing for us it has
this
insertion syntax to avoid sql injection
uh it also
parametrizes the types in the sense that
you get something back something binary
back from the database the db api spec
takes that and turns it into python type
so if i do type of this
you can see i'm getting a tuple so it's
a list of tuples with python types so
already there you know there's a bunch
of magic happening right
but
this this probably doesn't look great to
work with um
so
why is that
well the curious we're dealing with raw
strings as programmers as pythonistas
manipulating strings is not why we're
into writing python right
also if i was to take this toy example
and switch over to my sql server
database i would have to install a
completely different library rewrite all
the text and actually change the code
because i have to use the sqlites
connection
so if it was cx oracle for
[Music]
oracle databases or pi odbc for
mysql i would actually have to change my
code
uh and i'm actually not using any of the
power of python again it's all string
manipulation right so that doesn't feel
very iconic
so let's try to do the same thing but
this time with sql alchemy
uh
i personally like to import sql alchemy
as essay uh sort of like the pi data
vibe of two letter uh
abbreviations
uh mainly because yeah you do use the
sequel alchemist course stuff a lot that
is a personal preference and it's of
course up to you
so the first thing we need to talk about
is the various objects that
that sql output provides so the first
one we need to know about is the
metadata
so the metadata
keeps track of all the different tables
that a sql company is in charge of so
it's sort of a global register for sql
alchemy to work with and where does all
this look up so when you're doing joins
and stuff like that
it also is quite handy in the sense that
it knows the order in which things need
to be created so if you have
dependencies between your tables the
metadata registry knows
how to figure that out if you need to
create a table or drop a table
so of course now we need a table that is
of course the fundamental unit of
working with sql
so
we have a table object here
notice i gave it the name and then i
also passed it the meta the meta object
here and that's to register it into the
metadata
and then i have this column construct
here which basically is how uh sql
algorithm keeps track of the types of
the various columns
so i declare a column name column one of
type integer and i call them a call name
call two or type string
of course this is the very simple basic
types but just matching the previous
example
so now we have a table
the third part that we need is the
engine so this is sort of the the active
parts this is the part that actually
talks to the database and translates sql
alchemy things into sql in the database
so
the fundamental construct is the create
engine
that gives you an engine object from a
connection string
so one caveat here
we are in the transition period in c
gloccamy again it's a very long proj a
very old project
2.0 is right around the corner
so to smooth the transition what they've
done is
let you set this future equals true flag
that lets you opt into cql commute 2.0
behavior so if you pass this feature
equals true you're basically working in
2.0
when that rollover happens then you'll
be prepared you're not going to have any
surprises
it's also much nicer to work in trudeau
it's much more consistent
it's it's much clearer what's going on
and doesn't have as many warts as the
old one which is of course what happens
when you
go to a
major version bump
so we create our engine and now i'm
actually ready to do something
so let's write some sql so now i'm
writing the same sql query as before but
now i'm using python objects instead
so i i do a select on the test table
and that creates again a python object
and the overwrite the wrapper
so i get this selectable object but if i
print it
it actually generates the sql shows me
what sql is going to be one
so it gives you a lot of introspection
in terms of what's going to happen
sequel alchemy is not going to try to
surprise you
by doing something else that what it's
promised to do
it also overrides a bunch of operators
so for example i can do
this column notice i have the dot c to
access the columns so it's actually
called columns but because we use a lot
you can also use dot c
i column one equals test
so that gives me this binary expression
object
so that note means that sql alchemy can
actually translate that into
some sql so this would be the equivalent
sql of what i just wrote
so adding a where clause is actually
fairly simple
i can
tag on influent programming style dot
where
and then just write what looks like
regular python this equals that
and that will generate
a select
from test where
as you would expect
to run it
we do a connection just as like like we
did in the db api style
and then we execute the sql
and then we say all means get all the
results
so it looks the same right
visually
but
it's actually a bit of an upgraded
version because this is no longer tuple
it's a sql sql alchemy engine row so
this row object it has for example dot
dot
access so i can do dot column one
in previous one it was tuples i had to
do indexing which isn't very pleasant
it means i can convert it directly to a
dictionary
which is very useful if you're trying to
pass things through for example pedantic
or in your api
so notice here that i use dot all so dot
all is sort of a go do this everything
we've been doing until now is lazy until
i hit that dot all
so you can say that all get all of them
get one that's the first guess one
results
but also raise an exception if there's
only one so it also gets some if you're
doing you know aware to look up a
customer id you expect one results if
there is none there is an exception
one or none
same with but it's okay if there's none
first
the same as saying you know limit one or
a top one for you sql people sql server
people
then you can also do things like
streaming results we're not going to
talk about that today but know that that
is an option depending on your database
driver
so
the different uh
libraries for talking databases have
different options in terms of talking to
the database so for example if you're
working with postgres
it's very nice to have server side
cursors you can send your you know 10
million row results keep it in memory in
the database and then ask for chunks of
it at a time sql alchemy supports that
fully through streaming
so behind the scenes
yes
yeah so that's the concept of the cursor
right so you uh create a cursor you send
the sql to the database that cursor then
contains all the data on the database
side and then you're fetching sort of
whatever is in that cursor until it's
exhausted
no
there are some things where you can
actually sort of connect have a
streaming live update but that's that
wouldn't be a server-side cursor
so and again these aren't sql alchemy
features per se they're just supporting
features that are in modern databases so
if your modern database supports it and
the python database driver supports it
then clock me likely also supports it
so what did actually happen behind the
scenes here so it generated the correct
sequel for our database so
sql alchemy is database aware so for
example if you are in sql serverland a
limit would be called top right
c clock knows that it will automatically
convert a limit to a top
if there are any types or casting or
anything like that it knows how to
convert between most things there are
some things that are database very
specific
so cqlogme does support it
but in most cases it will do a
conversion automatically depending on
the connection string
it wraps the result of the query in this
row object which gives a nice access to
to each row
and behind the scenes which we didn't
see is that hugely has a pool of
connections by defaults
so that means
it doesn't check out and it doesn't
create a new connection every time you
make a call it has a pool of warm live
connections that are then rotates
between
so that means that you you can
uh sort of have lots of lots of queries
going
and not open hundreds of connections
because you can reuse the connections in
the connection pool so these are some of
the things that secrecy is doing for you
behind the scenes that you don't get out
of the box and others
so that was sort of a very brief
overview of
sql academy and why we like it
but and now we're going to dive into the
the cloud core are there any questions
yeah
so
uh is it more for the software
yeah so i mean
sleek alchemy i would say is for the
pythonista in general i would say
anywhere that you are today writing text
sequel and show hands how many here are
writing text sql
yeah you should probably be using sql
acme instead it gives you uh all the
power of python and doesn't let you make
the same mistakes that you can do in
text or sql so that's sort of the target
audience and then like in python in
general right you can start very easy
and then you can build up all the layers
of complexity
and we're going to talk about some of
those layers from text editor today
[Music]
you can tell them to take this class
afterwards
yeah but i think we can take that at the
end of this okay yeah
any questions on the sql alchemy part
before we move on
excellent
uh i i get very enthusiastic when i talk
about stuff so i speak quickly and fast
so if i ever do need to slow down just
raise your hand and then i will try to
accommodate
so core sequel um
so then as i mentioned it's built on
layers so c clock move itself is of
course built on db api
and the orm which we're looking later is
actually built on top of core so that's
why it's always important to understand
your building blocks
and this is probably what i would show
people who are used to writing textual
sql because it maps very easily to those
constructs but with extra benefits
so the first thing we have to do is to
have some data
so i have
cleaned up some data from open data dk
which has some data about parking
available parking in various areas so
the details aren't that interesting but
we also have some sample data to work
with
so as before the first thing we need to
do is actually create some tables so
this is more of a closer to real life
example that you might do at work
or for fun
if you're like me so of course we import
sqlcommy we create our metadata database
and then we have to create our tables
just like before so now we can get a bit
more interesting with the with the types
because cqlogma has a rich
database type system and then knows how
to convert those rich types back into
python types later
so we have some you know ids some
foreign keys
some varchars integers
so notice that we have we can also set
up these four key relationships we can
tell sql communities are primary keys
we can add uniqueness identifiers all
those fun things that you're used to
from from sql but i'm driving it all
from from python
so if i run this
nothing is actually going to happen
everything we've done here is sort of in
memory on python side we haven't talked
to any databases at all
cql acme does support what's called
reflection so if you have an existing
database and you're too lazy to type out
this you can do something that's called
the reflection
where you pass it the engine and then
it'll look up all these types and sort
of give you this table back
in general i recommend writing it out
because you don't have to write every
single column this is just the columns
that you need python to be aware of
again because it's all happening on this
side not on the database side
but it gives you an expensive schema
and it also allows you to do things like
migrations
and
easier introspection of what is it
actually you have available right
so in general this is what you're going
to be doing
so we have our facts which is the
parking table with accounts per hour
per year month per area
we have a dim area which says something
about the area where is it in the city
street name that sort of thing and then
we have
some different parking types kind of
like in enum
so given that we
are starting a new database because we
are going to be running our own for
those who have docker installed
you can
uncomment this and then run it i'm going
to be demoing this with postgres because
it's more of a gives you a bit more of a
proper database feel if you do not have
docker installed you want to follow
along
you can uncomment this bottom one then
you'll be running with the sqlites which
is that file database that we saw
previously and that's all built into
python
but as mentioned i'll be running in
actually let me open my database editor
first
who you know that pycharm has a full jet
sql integration
yeah it's awesome uh
one of the best reasons to get a pro
license
actually pay for
myself uh
so yeah so we set up our connection
string the connection string will vary
depending on what database you have uh
again for your oracle people i'm very
sorry
we use oracle it works as well
so
sql may use that connection stream to
infer what database apis and each
drivers need to load and all these
things so of course you need to still
have your database driver application
installed in a sense that you need for
postgres something like cycle pg2
for oracle cx oracle uh and pi obviously
you still need to have those installed
but the sql me will know which one to
use based on the prefix in this case
postgresql
so if we look at our meta you can
actually see it's a this type called
facade dictionary so i can actually
look up
a given table in here
if i could type
oh
it helps if i pass the right area so i
can actually grab the tables that i
defined out of the metadata and that's
actually what's happening in behind the
scenes in sequel alchemy
and it's the same thing if you do the
reflection it'll populate the metadata
tables and you can grab them out of
there
but actually interact with a database
again we need to create a connection
make sure we set future equals true
and now we can use the metadata object
to create all
and if i
open up
my database editor over here
probably should have done that before
you came up
let's see i believe it was just postgres
postgres
so that it connects and
we should see that we now have in the
public schema
we have three tables dimension partner
types and fact parking so it created all
those for me
with the appropriate you can see the
keys here
we have some foreign keys maps like all
that sql actually just took care of it
for me
which is very nice
of course it has a dropball counterpart
which will drop all the tables that it
knows about so again dropbox is not
going to drop all the tables and
database only the ones defined in the
metadata
so if we want to insert something
we can create a sql statement so
i'm sure you've all written an insert
into
the statement before the sql acme
version maps pretty closely to most of
the sql constructs
so
essay.insert
into the table the imparking types dot
values the device i want to insert
and that converts nicely into what you
would expect
and again i cannot do sql injection sql
acumen does not let me do sql injection
so that's a nice added benefit if you're
trying to sell to your colleagues
it'll automatically create these uh
parameters and do parameters queries
you can also do the all the tables have
some helper methods to generate this
sequel for you so for example the
inserts we can just do it straight on
the department types that insert and
that'll generate the exact same sql
so again to actually execute we need to
open a connection in a width block
general rule always always always use a
width block unless you have very good
reason not to i might break that rule in
this demo because it's a it looks a bit
prettier if i'm not opening with having
with blocks all the time but always
always always use with block
that'll make sure you don't have
lingering connections and your dbas will
be very very happy with you
so now i just executed that sql so if i
go back to the database we would expect
something right
wrong
sql alchemy doesn't presume
that you want to actually commit the
data that's because you alchemy works is
something called unit of work which
we'll cover in a bit
but if i actually want to say yep i'm
sure now i'm ready then you have to call
commit
everything is inside of a transaction
so if i go back now and refresh
now i have the data in there
we can delete some rows
again i have this helper method on the
table dot delete
and i can chain on a where clause
and that will give me a classic delete
from
again parametrized again no sql
injection
i execute that make sure it commits
and then we can go back and see
it's gone as you would expect
so this is what we call commit as you go
you have to tell sql alchemy that now is
the time to commit
so if you do you can also call rollback
so you can se you can control the date
of the uh
the flow of data so if you're whatever
reason you're not happy
then you can roll back at any points and
that'll basically undo everything up
until the last commit
so if i do the inserts and then commit
that and then delete it or roll back
would i have data in my database or
would i have no data in my database
i would have data should we check
and i do have data
so of course uh
i inserted i committed so that part is
sort of sent to the database and
persisted
new transaction
i run some more sql i'm not happy with
that i roll back everything gets thrown
out up until the last commit that gives
you a lot of safety uh when you're
working with with sql accommodate like
you're not accidentally going to delete
something
unless you sort of explicitly say it
tell it to commit
i mean this the selection or the
oh this one
yeah
yes exactly yeah because we
you don't commit so it doesn't actually
happen so the rollback is more of a
i've done all these things make sure you
throw them away it's an explicit way of
saying
don't keep it anymore
because remember this data is still in
it's been sent to the database it just
hasn't been committed
so i might have some more things that i
want to do in this block afterwards that
i do want to commit so it gives you that
it can give you a fairly fine level of
control yep over there can you just give
us an example
uh so actually we'll
try catch is interesting we'll get back
to that in a bit but it would be
that you for example try optimistically
to do something and you have something
else to do afterwards it's not something
that you really normally do because we
have some other methods which are sort
of safer by defaults but if you're doing
something more intricate
where you have multiple things talking
to the database at the same time within
the same transaction like you have
multiple functions that are sending data
to the database
you generally want to have one
connection being passed to all these
functions
and inside one function maybe you figure
out that oh no actually something
happened another function that means i
shouldn't do this after all then you can
roll back that bit
and everything else sort of carry on
as if it
never happened
so yeah so the rollback part in general
you're not going to use it 80 of the
time but it is being it is happening
behind the scenes and a lot of things
were going on to look at right now
so it's very useful to know about
so that comes back to this idea of unit
of work
so
a lot of other frameworks uh especially
uh
in ruby like active record they work
on sort of i want to modify this row and
then i want to modify this row and then
i want to modify this row
so you clock me says well instead of
doing that
i'm going to get all the things that you
want to do and then i'm going to then
when you're ready then i'll send it all
to the database and because then i can
sort of optimize things bit behind the
scenes
uh in terms of how the queries get sent
and what data gets sent and how we flush
so for with sqladme instead you want to
run all your sqls
and then commit when you're done so for
example if you're
writing a web api you probably want to
open your connection when you get a
request do all your things
then then commit and then it all gets
sent to the database in sort of one unit
that's why it's called one unit of work
so
everything starts in interaction
whenever we open a new connection block
then it actually starts a new
transaction in the database
you can also manage that connection a
transaction starter manually if you want
to
with the begin
so we can again execute this delete we
can commit it we can start a new
transaction
execute and then roll back the
transaction
so
do we have data do we not have data
so we have data hands up
do we not have data hands up
excellence
as you're
wires to the ways of sql
so yeah we don't have data because again
we explicitly design manage our
transaction and roll back that
transaction
usually we don't need this level of
control it's very rare that we actually
explicitly work with transactions
so
sql document provides this other form if
you want to explicitly make sure that
everything is running inside a
transaction because you have multiple
transactions you want to do or you just
want to not have to remember to commit
which is also something that can be
quite nice
then you can do this dot begin so dot
begin will automatically create a
transaction for you
run
the sql
and if you do have an exception then
it'll roll back for you
if it if there is no exception it'll
commit
so if i run my insert my deletes
i should have
data no data
there you go
no data
so committed both at the end
if i have an exception here i insert
raise the exception something bad
happens
data no data
no data
so that gives you a nice safety net
if you have if you use this dot begin
pattern it'll automatically roll back if
you have a transaction
so of course you can always implement
your own try catch uh exception
uh if you want
and then you can like get more fine
grains so sql locking does provide you
these level of extraction abstraction
depending on where you want to be
uh so what if we have lots of rows that
we want to insert right now we've been
playing with these toy examples um
including the repo there is this the csv
of the actual data that we're talking
about because again we just created some
tables we haven't actually put any data
into these databases
so we just have traditional insert
statement query stuff uh grab each of
these csvs
in a tuple together with the the table
we want to insert into
we open a dot begin because again this
this is an example of where we have
multiple things happening right we want
to roll everything back if
only if one of them fails
so then we iterate over the tuple get
the data file and the table
open it
grab the data as a list of dictionaries
create the sql in this case just insert
and then we can use this other syntax
that we haven't seen before so we can do
an execute pass sql and then pass the
parameters explicitly
so when you pass a list of dictionaries
with keys matching the table columns
uh sql alchemy knows okay now now i need
to do an execute menu
so in the db api spec there's a
difference between an execute which does
sort of one thing and execute many which
is optimized for multiple typical
inserts or deletes
so sql alchemy will take care of you
as long as you pass it to list of
dictionaries
and then you get a bunch of speed ups
again depending on your db driver
so if we look into our database now we
should have
a bunch of data
and the facts
so
i'm not getting a count up here that's
okay
yeah there's some couple thousand rows
in there
i just have something to play around
with so this is how you this is very
typical insertion logic in python so
replace csv file here with parquet or
some other sql or a data frame or
something like that
so now we're ready to actually write
some some logic that's the fun part
right
unless you're a dba or a data engineer
you might not be doing a lot of
insertion you might be doing more
selects
so
i've lined up a couple of tasks that i
want to get done
so you're going to learn a bit about the
danish geography so that's fun
and then pronunciation which is even
more fun i'm not danish i just happen to
speak it
so task one get only accounts for gilai
uh
lovely image pronunciation
so what we can do is we can do a select
and we refer to the columns with the
table dot c dot table name so we want
the count we want the hour
and then we want all everything from the
area table so that's sort of like a
select star if we don't pass anything
we do join to the area and we pass aware
so you can see it has this like fluent
chaining syntax which you might be
familiar with from
example working in pandas which makes it
really nice to modify the the sql
so if we print it you can see it looks
pretty much as you would expect select a
number of columns from some tables
joined with another table
did you notice that sql alchemy actually
figured out the join key for you
that is actually one of the really nice
things so because we specified a foreign
key relationship you do not have to
worry about it you just
join it and see what can you figure it
out it'll tell you if you can't figure
it out if for example you have multiple
foreign keys or if there are some other
reasons why i can't figure it out
most of the cases it'll just figure it
out
uh so now we can actually execute it we
can get all of them and we get back this
row objects that's a list of a list of
these rows
so i can do traditional row sizing i'll
get the top five and then print the
dictionaries
and you can see okay that looks
reasonable
it's probably not how you normally want
to work with data if you're at pi data
so of course you can throw it straight
into a data frame
that will get you a nice data frame
because of course data frame supports
lists of dictionaries and the results
object can be coerced into a dictionary
so the row objects can easily be
corresponds to dictionary
and of course
pandas knows all about c me it actually
uses it under the hood every time you do
anything dot dot two sequel or read
sequel so you can pass the sequel and
the connection straight to
read sql and pandas will know what to do
with it
uh one caveat when we're working with
2.0 pandas it doesn't quite compatible
with 2.0 yet they need to do like a big
rewrite of the sql internals in general
so you do need to open a
connection like this and then pass it to
the to its equal function it doesn't
know how to do that itself quite yet
so
let's get a bit more complicated
let's actually have some mathematics so
i want to know the sum of counts like
how many parking spots were available
per hour per city
so normally you would write in sql you
write some something and then do a group
by
uh it works pretty much the same way so
sql alchemy has this magic object called
a func
and this func any attribute call to it
will map to the corresponding
sql function
so sqlockem doesn't actually know about
all the functions that are defined in
sql server or
whatever database you're working in it
knows some of them so it does do some
conversion but basically just takes
whatever you put after that func and
says okay that's the function i'll just
pass it with those parameters
so in this case i say that func.sum of
this count column
has to give it a label otherwise it's
going to be
anonymous
and then i have to include my grouping
columns
i have my join and then i do a group i
and again i just pass in the columns
that i want to group by
so i want you to take away that
writing these sql core statements is
very very similar to writing regular sql
you should be able to fairly easily take
medium complex complexity sequels and
map them one to one in c clock and core
to get started
so if we run that just to verify that
looks right
and then we execute it get the data
frame and we can see we have city hour
pairs and a total count
so
this sequel
i mean it's not bad but it looks like
sequel uh and again
we're not writing sql we're writing
python
so you're asking how we can convince our
fellow colleagues that sql alchemy is a
good idea
you can actually refactor your sql how
many people can say that about their
text strings right
so i can split out the different parts
and give them variable names so i can
for example
pre-join the tables called table
i can
create this metric total count which is
these sata thunk.sum
and then finally i can
i have some dry right i'm repeating the
group by columns in both the select and
the group i that's a common pane in all
sql right
so i can actually
create a list of those columns
and now i can turn my sql statement into
total counts
dimension calls
select from table group by dimension
goals
so now my sql statement is quite terse
but at the same time fairly readable
because especially if you're working
with aggregations in sql they get very
long
until you figure out what's actually
going on at the end when you read the
label
so if we run this
we get the same
just for comparison this is what it
looked like before
uh let's actually print this as well
that'll help
so that you can tell on that line
creates the same sql
so as an aside this fluent style of
chaining makes it really really easy to
modify the sql in place
so what you can do is that you can on
the fly
update the sql because every statement
just creating a new statements
so i can add a new group by column
i can add a new select column
so there was the group by down here
three
and up here and i'm not changing the
original sql that's the important part
so part of the power of this is that you
can write reusable functions in logic
that takes in a sql statement modifies
it returns it
and then you all of a sudden you can
have you know the holy grail
metrics functions group by functions
that's long sql query that you have to
calculate some random
business objects put that into a
function you don't have to look at it
anymore you can just say here's the
sequel add this crazy long
function to it
so that was on the side
but it is a part of the power that we
get out of using c gloccum so again we
can exhibit execute it notice i'm
dynamically adding a limit statement
here so again i'm just modifying the sql
to add a limit which gets translated
into the backend sql
and now i have the top 10.
so now let's get even more complicated
uh let's calculate some occupancy rates
so the occupancy rates in this case
we're defining it as available parking
spots and use parking spots at a given
time
uh so
just to check how many do you know what
a cte is common table expression
what about nested sub queries
okay
so basically i'm going to be using a cte
a ct is basically a way of creating an
intermediate table so you can
have a select statement and you can kind
of name it and then you can treat that
select statement as if it was a table
so that's basically what it is
it looks pretty confusing the first time
you use it but they're super super handy
when you're writing sql in general
but so in order to do the calculation
right i need to match up because my fact
table if we looked at
over here so i have the account type and
the count type
is legal or counted
so i actually have in my facts i have
two tables sort of appended on top of
each other i have all the table all the
parking spots there are
followed by all the parking spots are
counted
so i need to sort of break these two
apart and put them next to each other so
that i can do that that division across
the tube
and panda's right would be fairly simple
because you can just do the two selects
and then
divide across them and sql it gets a bit
more funky
but with the power supply alchemy we can
hopefully simplify this expression so
that we can break it down into small
parts and then just run a small sql
statement at the end
so one thing we can do is we have the
space select statements which is
basically going to be our fact table
together with our parking types that'll
give us
the counts and whether or not it is
occupied or legal
i'm going to be reusing those so i can
write it once and i can just refer to it
so available spaces would be a
a cte where we select
partner types equals legal so now i have
the available spaces table
the counter spaces is the same except
now i'm doing it with counted equal to
counted my metric of interest is
i have to cast two floats because we're
getting a percentage
uh multiply by 100 available spaces
uh sorry uh counter space is divided by
available spaces and label so again like
that's already getting pretty long
because we have to handle all this uh
conversion stuff right
so it's pretty nice to get that out of
the way and give it a nice label
so i can just say refer to it as
occupancy rate
and the joint condition
we can no longer automatically infer it
because we're creating these temporary
tables there are no foreign keys for it
to match right
so our join statement actually gets a
bit long
but again we can abstract that into a
variable because we have to do it by
area id and join on month and join on
the hour because those are the things we
want to calculate by
and then i can create the join
so i can do available spaces join the
counter spaces so now i'm mapping
together and the join condition is
already defined
and now i can actually write my sql
so
now i can actually read it and say okay
i want the occupancy rates
the city
the year month and the hour
okay that makes sense in my head that's
what i'm you know trying to get
if i print out the sql
that's a lot longer
i don't know about you but i prefer the
my version that's i am biased
so if you run this
and notice i can even pass in the inline
stuff like order by
so again
the sql alchemy gives us a bunch of
helper methods so i want order by
descending
the order the occupancy rates is x
sorry a column so that has a desk method
on it which will convert the order by
into a order by descending
and then i get the occupancy rate
city year month an hour
so if you are in scanable then sucks to
be you if you're in savvy then you have
lots of parking available
that makes a lot more sense if your
danish
so
i hope that you got the notion that
c clock macor
is sql just in python
so
uh how we on time
thank you very much
so i have a quick exercise here for you
uh i'm going to give you
five minutes to to give it a go
so basically
i want you to find
all the rows where the occupancy rate is
above
100.
make sure you've executed all the cells
before you attempt this exercise
um
i mean that would be nice uh if you want
to start a new open source project then
that sounds like a great idea
no uh so so there is like the get out of
jail free card which is the text
construct
so there is a thing called essay.text
you pass it sql and then
it'll treat it as if it was already
compiled by sqlcommy
so
it would be the same as if you were to
define the whole sequel in c alchemy
style and then sort of have run it
but it's not going to decompose it into
the various objects
i haven't tried if you were able to do
for example the replace
selectings that i actually do not know
that but that's you can that you can
actually try for yourself uh
let's see if you can do the uh
what did i do
add a new group by column and uh or add
a new select column
so
sql alchemy is quite deep when you get
into it so there are lots of handy
little tricks like that so if you do try
it let me know i'll be curious
um
so
give it two more minutes
all right how are we looking
do we need a bit more time
so how many how many of you this was the
first time you ever wrote an ec black me
all right cool congratulations
so i think we'll we'll call it there how
many managed to solve the uh exercise
uh i don't have the counters more if it
worked
you should look at the data and see that
you don't have any more than uh
or they're all above 100.
but uh
the idea is that you can chain off of
the previous sql that we have that's the
uh
you always have to have a trick right
with these questions
so if i have the sql
that's just a table
uh
dodge occupancy rates
actually let's uh
i was just talking about how much nicer
it is to have name variables
now i have to remember how to do this
too right
see that
oh
cupancy
yeah so there is some uh
some new things going on that are
deprecated that's why you always have to
be
a bit careful uh but that's why we have
that future thing because uh sometimes
things will work and then tomorrow
they're not gonna work because then c
blockme2.0 comes out
so here they're saying that they want me
to do a ct that's fine
did i misspell something
yeah i did
that's the dots accuracy rate
there always good thing to
double check
so now i can do
t dot c dot
occupancy great
that where
t dot c dot
so there are lots of ways you could have
done this
there are many ways to roam in in sql
and therefore many ways your moments you
glock me
yeah naming things is hard guys
with engine.connect
r is equal to cons.execute
t sql
dot all
data type mismatch great
it helps if i actually have a work where
clause
and then if i
throw this into dataframe
that looks great to me
so i hope
at least you've got a good effort
but as many of these questions is a
trick right knowing that you can chain
these methods onto the previous sequel
and sql acme does help does have pretty
good error messages you can see that
when i did the old-fashioned way it
actually warned me that hey you should
be doing this with the cte
when i misspelled the column name it
actually told me that like this this
column doesn't actually exist
so cool
are you guys ready for rms or do we have
any questions on core
mind blown
sure thing
feel free to give me better names
so the question was will speak optimize
optimizer query
no it'll not change your sql query like
the text of it what it will do is it'll
try to optimize the way it sends it to
the database um
but sqladmin does not presume to know
your intent when it comes to the to the
sql when we talk about core uh when we
talk about orm it's a bit more fuzzy but
yeah
that's also part of the sneaky
abstraction thing we were talking about
that if we try to hide
like the uh
sql code from the python code then it
starts doing things that you don't
expect and that that's part of the
design principles of sql alchemy is that
it doesn't try to hide anything it's not
trying to be a
a sql writer it's trying to be a sql
yeah parsing engine let's call that
cool anyone else
then let's dive into the wonderful world
of orms
so the orm is actually where a lot of
people get their starts in sql alchemy
they're usually coming from
something like django
they're used to working in the orm there
maybe now they're trying out some api
language like flask or fast api
and they're like where's my orm
and then they find out that oh sql
camera has an rm great
in my opinion that's the wrong way to
learn sqlcommy
because again the orm does magic
that's kind of what orms do
they are mapping a python class to a sql
row
that's that's what an object relational
mapper does
that means that by its very nature
there is magic going on to sort of
convert between those two things
which sounds the same thing but usually
aren't
so learning
core first lets you
always have that escape hatch
of okay now i'm doing something
i can just drop down into core and write
it so it does it the way that i needed
to do it
and is one of the actually the core part
in the pun features of sql alchemy that
you can always switch in between because
orm is just building on top of core
so when would you use it uh so my rule
of thumb is orms are great if you're
talking about single rows so that's why
it's very common in something like
django or in an api you're doing request
response get me this customer get me
this purchase get me this uh blog post
then it works great if you're only
working with one road a time and
manipulating that or a handful let's say
then orms are great
if you're working with analytics in any
way you want to do counts sums
aggregations of any kind
core will probably be better for your
use case
because there's also one caveat
if you were to select
100 000 rows
and then convert them into python
objects
that's not fast
converting them into pi into c clock
rows is a lot faster
so
just keep that in mind that
you want to think about tens and not
thousands when you're talking about orm
so again the first thing we always need
to do is to define our tables that's how
sql alchemy knows what's
what it's got to work with
so the way we do that is actually fairly
different because now we're talking
about classes
so the
classic way and i'll show you this
because every single sql option tutorial
you see out there is going to be using
this way until everyone migrates to new
2.0 style
is to run this function which returns a
class
and then you will subclass
this derived class
and then write your
your own class on top of that
so remember this library was written way
before we had
type checkers before we had linters
this does not make my pie happy
it does not make a lot of linting
libraries happy in fact some of them
have coded in special exceptions for c
clock me again because c block me so
pervasive
but in general we don't want to return a
class or even not even an instance of a
class a type of a class from a function
right
that looks odd
but that's how it was done
so that's you can still do that that's
not going away
so you you create your your base class
here and then you subclass it
you always have to give it a table name
and that's going to be what the name of
the table in the database is going to be
so the rule of thumb here is in its in
your database you probably want plurals
you want customers
uh in orem you usually you have one
customer at a time so there you're one
singular one customer right
and the other the rule is that a orm
class has to define a primary key you're
not allowed to have a
rm object does not have a primary key
because that's how sql alchemy keeps
track of the individual objects in its
own internal representation
so if you can't fulfill those two things
then oms are not for you
but yeah but that's that's basically how
you do it and when you do that behind
the scenes there is again this metadata
object being created it's inside of this
base class
and this table gets registered
but in 2.0 one of the nice new features
is this that they
revamped this registry system
so now we can create a registry instead
and then this registry
can be used to decorate your class
with dot maps
and that sort of fits in more with how
we think about these things these days
right we have data classes we have
adders uh function classes that use this
pattern uh having a class decorator is
not a crazy thing to do right
also fits more in with a registry
pattern in general
but the same rules still apply you still
need a table name you still need your
primary key
and in this case we just have a random
address
but it's just a class so i can add a
nice wrapper to it that shows me sort of
the key data
and then you know that will be printed
out
the other nice thing that it does i
remember remember i told you that om is
just building on top of core
it just auto creates the c clock record
table
in this under table attribute so it's
right there you can you can go grab it
and work with it and do whatever you
need to do
uh
notice that we're not finding in inits
so this is actually something
that's because again this predates data
classes and adders and all these things
this is one of the first libraries that
i had this i'll create and in it for you
based on class variables
so cyclone will automatically create an
init that accepts these
but you are free to define your own in
it if you want to either restrict
what you want to accept
or if you want to do some you know
post-processing of the input arguments
before you create your for instance
that's perfectly fine
let's
finish up our data models so we have we
have our address we have let's have a
purchase
i have this table arcs here
orms don't really work well in notebooks
they're not meant for that
so
par oh sorry sql alchemy will complain
that i'm going to be redefining these
classes throughout the notebook uh
because it messes with this internal
registry
so i have this extend existing just
means that it's okay i know what i'm
doing i'm opting out of this checking
behavior it'll still complain with a
warning so don't worry about that
but just to let you know so just ignore
this line this is for notebook purposes
only
but yeah so the definition is pretty
much exactly the same
i have a foreign key
i use these columns i have for example a
decimal
the nice thing is i can add these high
pins again we're writing modern python i
can add tie pins to my
attributes here clock me doesn't care
about them yet there's actually a
feature that's coming up that you can
do type hinting
to instead of writing these essay.com
things
but it's not a feature yet
so right now it's just for my own
my own sake it helps
when we write our code
we can also use more exotic types like
we can use an enum
so for the customer
these customers have a status they can
be gold silver bronze
so then we can set the status to be of
type enum
and then we get to the cool part about
orms
which is relationships which is to me
the killer feature
so notice here that i define two
relationships address so a customer has
an address and purchases a customer has
many purchases
so what does that actually mean so
i still have my database up and running
if you don't then you have to recreate
it
so
we have a new keyword here
and again oms are magical they will
create and run sql on your behalf that
you have no control over
per se
so when you're getting used to working
with the orm you can turn on this echo
equals true then sql alchemy will print
out every sql statement it is
writing and running
so that gives you that extra level of
control when you're developing that's
okay it is actually doing what i think
it's doing because especially with orms
they're going to be doing a lot more
calls than you think they're doing
and then i'll do the same thing notice
that on the map registry that's where my
metadata lives now so i can just access
it through there
and here's our first example of all the
stuff that clapping actually does for me
some highlights is that actually checks
do these tables actually exist already
if not skip them
in a cross database agnostic way
and then actually runs all the creates
and creates all the primary keys and
foreign keys and all those references as
we saw before
and now i'm ready to actually create
some data
so you just create an instance it's just
instances of class
i have john jane here
they're not
i haven't again i haven't talked to the
database yet they're just a class
with attributes dot name
and dot status
everything you would expect
from a python class nothing up my
sleeves
so the way you talk to your database in
rm is with a thing called session you're
no longer working with a direct
connection object you're working with a
session because the section adds some
extra abstractions on top like keeping
track of what is already loaded into
memory what is not
loading primary keys into memory so it
can access
various data
so we need the session
thing instead
but the pattern looks very similar in
the sense that we create an instance of
session give it the engine in a width
block and that's we're just going to
call session.execute instead of
con.execute
so pretty close but not quite
so in the session
we add these objects and then c-clock we
make sure that uh
now it knows to keep track of them
again i still have to actively commit
it's still an opt-in commit so if i
commit that
you can see we get the inserts
and
notice speaking of optimizing sql
queries i have from this
i get one insert
that is parametrized i'm not getting two
insert statements
and that's that unit of work
in in action because the session knows
oh i have two of these two of these
things that aren't committed then i can
optimize what i'm sending to the
database and write the sql in a way that
optimizes for that inserts so instead of
sending 100 it will send one insert with
many parameters
so now we can add an address
and we can do that in many ways but one
way is to just assign it to the
attributes
so now john has an address
so now if i re-add john and commit that
so you clock me will notice hey
john now has an address he didn't have
one before and doesn't exist
so let's insert into addresses this new
address
and then we select again
to refresh
the session
because we update we have to make sure
that john himself hasn't changed and
then we update him to insert the address
id of the newly created address
so if we jump into the database and look
at what actually happened
so this is the magic part of the ograms
right
having to keep track of
relationships
across tables is a pain
so i have my address and then i have
john with address id of one
that's pretty cool
notice that jane here she doesn't have
an address yet so she's just null
so john goes shopping and he buys a
magic potion
so when i create purchase because i set
this relationship up
uh if i go to purchase notice i didn't
set one on purchase
but
yeah the only thing about these sql
queries is they get pretty long you know
when you're doing the echo
we were down here somewhere
but this still works
so why do you think that works that's a
bit odd
well if we look at our customer here
you notice i set a relationship to the
address table backref equals customer so
backref is back reference
that means that what
also does is it registers on the address
class that hey
you have a relationship to customer you
know about until now but now you do
which means that it adds that attributes
to the address class or to the purchaser
class
and
any customer so you can do it manually
you can explicitly set a relationship on
each side
and then do back populates which will
say like there is a matching
relationship here
or you can set the back graph here and
then it will just
add that attribute for you
so that's more up to your encoding style
explicit versus implicit and all those
fun things but now if i add the potion
we see the same thing we select the
customer
so we got a fresh copy of the customer
we insert into the purchases
so this is going on
and then we insert it with the user id
but
again that's the caveat right
it's doing some magic for me but
i wouldn't be able to guess how many sql
statements that
simple operation would have done if i
wasn't quite very familiar with c
locally
so in this case i did two
it could have done lots more if there
were if there was more data
so caveat emptor
always make sure that you know what your
orem is doing
we can also just create a purchase
so we have our magic hat here
then i can again connect john to the
session because if john's not in the
session then sql acme doesn't know how
to look them up to make sure we get the
right
data
and it'll just complain and tell you hey
i'm not in a session so please add me
so when i have john
then i can append him to my purchases
attributes
and then
because equal me just rep represents
these relationships as a list
i can read and then i can commit
and again we're generating a bunch of
sql statements three in this case
but it also does some caching
which is nice to know that's a new
feature in 2.0 it does more aggressive
caching of your queries so the
compilation of the sql statements gets
cached by sql alchemy and that's what
it's telling you here that it it's
already seen in the sql so it doesn't
actually need to uh to recompile it
so now
if i go back into
my purchases i have two purchases and
they are both are mapped to the correct
user id
so this is this was my mind blown moment
when i started working with clockme
because doing this by hand
sucks that is like the worst part of
writing sql for some kind of api is
keeping track of all these related
objects and making sure that they're in
sync at all times
so
if it takes a few more sql calls to to
make that happen by magic then i'm
perfectly comfortable with that
so we have some data and how do you
actually now get that data back so the
big thing that happened to 2.0 was a
realignment
if you're looking at pre 2.0 then you
would have different syntaxes for
selecting depending on whether it was
orm or whether it was core
which meant that every time you googled
how do i
do this sequel in sql alchemy you always
have to make sure that you're either
looking at the orm version or the
core version
which was really annoying in 2.0 it's
been aligned now we're using the same
essay that selects whether or not it's
in orm or whether or not it's in core
and that's fantastic
only one api to learn right
so in the end you just say essay to
select customer it's the same thing as
if it was a table in core
uh filter by is just a nice syntax
instead of saying dot where
name equals equals jane you can do
filter by keyword arguments value
and just as the same so it's a
convenience method
and it creates the the correct sql
so and again the execution is almost the
same we're just using a session instead
of the connection but we do session
execute one or none
and we get our jane back
so especially one or none is something
you're going to be using a lot more if
you're using the orm because then you're
typically in a context where either the
customer exists or he or he does not
so you're fine either way but you just
need to know but if there are two
customers with the same value then you
probably did something wrong
so that's a nice level of safety you get
there
so and we have our customer chain
but wait that looks a bit odd
what happened here
so again
things changed a bit in 2.0 and if this
was 1.4
it would not look like this you'd get
your chain back and everyone wouldn't be
happy but now we're aligning our syntax
across core and orm and in core when you
do select
you get back a row object and you have
to access each value in it exact same
thing for
orm
so if i do jane
0 then i get jane back out
i actually don't remember is a name
customer yeah
so that basically get back your result a
row that has one one column in it and
that column is called customer and it
has j inside
so obviously that's a bit clunky
so
we introduced this thing called scalars
so scalar was actually a thing back in
the day as well but it wasn't necessary
for rm
now it is so scalar just says i want to
whatever is in the first row in the
first column that's the value i want
and if you're using
multiple then it's just whatever's in
the first column that's the value that i
want
so you tack on scalars to your executes
do one or none
and now we get back what we would expect
so
because this is such a common pattern in
2.0
we have a bunch of these helpers which
do it in a single method call instead so
you see scalar one or none scalar all
scalar versions of all the various
operations
but just know that just it just means
adding the scalars modifier to the
previous results access
so one more way because obviously in
python we like to have multiple ways
if you know the customer or the primary
key then you can use a sort of shortcut
syntax which lets the session
optimize the query
uh because it checks do i have this
already uh can i reuse something or do i
have to go fetch it
so if you do session.get on the table
and pass the primary key then i'll do
this optimization to to get out the
customer
and we get the same customer back
so now that we have our customers we can
start asking questions about
the related attributes we set up these
relationships and we probably did it
because we care about them
so let's put john back into the session
and then let's ask about his purchases
and his address
so we got
a bunch of sql being generated but all i
did was just access an attribute
so what's up with that
and if i do this
with a regular attribute there's no sql
being emitted at all
so this comes back into what
relationships uh actually are and why
you have to be a bit careful you see we
have here one selecting the customers we
have selected purchases and then we
select the addresses
so these two dots these three actually
created three sql statements even though
you're just doing attribute lookup
so this idea of relationship loading is
pretty important if you want to
really take advantage of relationships
so by default sql alchemy orms are lazy
if you're fetching a customer you're
only getting the rows from the customer
table because joins are
can be expensive so sql acme doesn't
want to presume that you automatically
want to get the join with all the
addresses or pushes imagine like if
you're a twitter and you get one
you know get all your posts or it's a
massive join right
so by default it's lazy because that's
the safest
if you don't know what's going on though
it becomes quite dangerous because then
you're doing attribute looks up every
attribute lookups everywhere not knowing
that you're constantly sending sql
statements to the database
which will be fine when you're in dev
and then you hit production all of a
sudden your scale increases by 10 folds
100 folds and your sql query is
increased by a thousand volts
so to get around this
you can explicitly in a query you can
explicitly say i want this to be done in
a different way
so when i select customer here i i can
pass this options
and i can say that the address
relationship should be done with a
joined load
and the purchases relationship should
then with it select in load
where customers name equals to john
so if we look at this now
so the if i get the customer here let's
see if you can find that
then you see i do a left outer join with
addresses so that's this is this join
load so then in one sql statement it's
doing a left join with the relationship
table and getting the all those in
because obviously we want to have all
the customers
but we also don't have an address that's
perfectly legitimate query
the other the other option is to do a
select in
so there we can select
the purchases where purchase a user id
in
primary key so there you're reducing it
to two
selected statements one to get the
customer and then another one to select
all the purchases
where the purchase id is in this part
this is a custom id
so again it comes down to two flavors
and uh
it's more up to you uh sort of exactly
how it should be done because you're the
one who knows the database
again sequel oximeter's philosophy is we
don't leak
we don't hide away the sql you are still
in charge of the database you know best
about how the database is structured
we're not going to make all these
assumptions for you
we can also set these up
from the start
so when i define my relationship i can
also say how should this by default be
done
so i can say lazy equals joined we'll do
the join load or laser equals selection
select in which you'll lose the selected
load so you can predefine that if you
know that every time you want that and
then you can opt into other behaviors
depending on your query
so
i'm going to skip over this exercise so
you're free to do this for yourself i
just want to talk about what some of the
nice things that orams give you on top
of relationships
which mainly are that orms are just
classes
and classes are first class contracts in
python
it gives you a lot of nice features for
example you can create a mix in so let's
say you want to have
two columns on every table that says
when was this created and when was the
last updated
normally you'd have to do that by hand
but you can just specify mixin
so if you haven't seen mixing before
it's just a name for a pattern where
you're not supposed to override it it
doesn't have behavior it just adds some
extra stuff to your class
and then
if i list my columns here you can see i
now have two more created ads
and some over here should be the yeah
there last updated and created that gets
automatically added to this class
[Music]
so the other nice thing is we can define
a class method so this is actually a
pretty powerful construct in python how
you define alternative constructors
especially if you're you know doing
serialization you get some json you want
to convert it into your class the
easiest way to do that is to create a
class method that defines okay from dict
i'll take addict and then creates the
class based on that so you can control
that behavior
so this is the warning i was talking
about that i'm redefining the class
which you should not be doing
for demo purposes only
so now i can create a user object from
dictionary
and sort of control that behavior
we also have properties like
is admin i can of course manually write
the code to check if this user is an
admin or not or i can add a property
which makes it look like it's an
attribute so now i can do
is admin false
the nice thing is that sql alchemy
actually lets you hook into this
behavior
in
in python
so
we have this thing called a hybrid
property so hybrid property just means
that
we tell c blocking hey this thing you
can actually use it in the sql statement
as
well so instead of defining a property
we define a hybrid property
and then we create all that
and we get a user
we
add that user
and now i can do in my sql statements
notice i'm using the
class because it's a class property and
not an instance property is admin
and that will compile into or uses that
role equals role
so now i have a nice class property that
i can use both after i get my instance
and in my sql statements
we can also verify those mixed in
while we're at it
so last updated 9 23 26
and 9 23 50.
so those are actually working as
intended as well
sometimes
the logic doesn't matter as easily in
this case property was a simple equals
that gets over overloaded in sql alchemy
and gives you as
a where clause
often is not that neat so let's say for
example that we have that the role can
be one of many so we're doing it in
that doesn't translate to sequel to me
so we need to specify the sql that gets
run in the sql world to match the result
from the python world
the way you do that is
you specify your hyper property this is
the python code and then you can do
another one it has to be named the same
and then you you say
the
proper name dot expression that tells
people alchemy this is where the sql
expression you should use comes from
and it's on the class level so you get a
class
and i can say class that role in this is
the way you say
usually create an in statements in a c
locate this list
so now i have my user
i have a property that i can access on
the instance
or i can use the is validated
so
just notice that because we're using a
bit of cpu magic it can't quite show you
what's going to happen because it needs
to do some extra processing of the query
parameters that come in so which is why
you get this funky post-compiled world
but it does work and
we get back
jade who was validated so
that's how you can do that
so we only have five minutes left uh so
i just want quickly to mention hybrid
methods
basically the same as a hyper property
it just works for methods instead
so let's say we have our purchase here
we want to define
the ability to calculate an roi on the
on our user here sorry so basically take
the sum of all those purchases and
divide it by the total cost
and that'll give us an roi on this
customer
so i need to have some information in
order to calculate this which is why i
can't be property uh i need the cost
so i execute oh
boom boom i'm sorry there's some
duplication here
don't write your demos late at night
people uh
here we go
so here we have a
jnr user
with the purchase of zero
i can also have a plain jane regular
method here uh purchase which just adds
to the purchase cost
notice that you can do nice things like
this where you can abstract away some
logic you can pass into the active
session and then actually work with the
instance
directly on the
on the method so this case i update the
purchases with the item cost and then i
persist that into the database
and then this roi method down here
[Music]
so now we have
some
purchases
so if we looked at here
notice it's actually selecting from the
database
the purchases and then i can actually
calculate the roi this is on the
instance so it's not doing any sql
but i can then use it in a where
statements so where roi is greater than
one for example
and that translates it into the correct
statements
so i can execute that and then i get
back my chain and then
her roi just to show that it was working
is greater than one
and with that i will close this session
so thank you very much for your time
so we have uh three minutes before alisa
i get kicked out you're free to say
you can ask some questions on here or
otherwise just meet me outside i'll be
here all weekend so
good timing
so yeah we got a question over
there with things like data glasses and
things like that but
this one's keep some extra functionality
like a good wrapper method
that is there to combine to choose
somehow
uh yeah actually uh that's one of the
imperatives for changing the way of
registering uh classes was explicitly to
support data class and adders so you can
actually
have your data class and then tell sql
alchemy this is the class that i want
you to use as sort of the serialization
class
and then it just works peanut butter and
chocolate
so
i would refer to the docs considering we
have two minutes um
but
if you do see glacomy
so the only it sounds amazing but it is
a bit more verbose because obviously it
has to do a bit more work oh that's the
one i wanted
see and i will plug the c clock
documentation they are fantastic um
they do a lot but a lot of work on it
so this whole section here is how you
can do exactly that so basically you
have to redefine everything twice
because you need the c blocking
representation of the table and your
data class representation so it's not as
pretty but you don't have to do it in
line like you could have your tables
definition somewhere else and then you
know just say set the table equal to it
because this is the piece of magic that
the
mapper also does is to generate this for
you
it's um
oh we have one all the way back over
there
excellent question so you're asking
about the data immigration database
migration tool for student
uh so the same guy who wrote c block me
also wrote alembic uh so basically
alembic lets you is able to read all
your sql community definitions and then
automatically create a migration based
on that by introspecting the target
database your models and creating a diff
of the two and then writing the ddl
to create the difference between the two
then also register when you apply it it
also registers in the database hey
version
blah blah blah
is the current one so it can always keep
them in sync
knowing what version your database is in
so then you can do like git style
upgrade downgrade between versions of
your database
so so check that out that's uh the
current gold standard for or at least
for c locally
thank you very much
[Applause]